and one last thought about this this
Fiasco yesterday in the Rose Garden I
want to play again the clip of Nancy
Pelosi just the very end of her of her
speech where she said she's gonna pray
for the President and the United States
of America play that clip he just took a
pass and it just makes me wonder why why
he did that in any event I pray for the
President of the United States and I
pray for the United States of America so
here's the thing this amounts to me to
being nothing more than when Republicans
respond to gun violence with thoughts
and prayers when they have the capacity
to do something about it right maybe she
was just trying to convey and I said
this earlier perhaps she was just trying
to convey a seriousness a somberness a
tone of a tone that is reflective of how
dire the situation is but that's just
the thing if you're trying to convey to
the American people that this situation
is so bad that it requires a moment of
reflection and a deep somber moment
appealing to a divine intervention into
our affairs if that's what you truly
believe then the u.s. speaker of the
house need to stop praying and start
impeachment don't pray impeach like what
you are literally the one person in this
country who has the ability to if not
get rid of the president put him on
notice with official articles of
impeachment because all you need in the
house is a simple majority draw up the
articles and vote and he can see and the
record could reflect that there was true
opposition not just the hashtag
movements not just the actual real
movements that are in the streets like
the movements that are actually doing
things but using our constitutional
institutions and and and regimes and
norms to
do what the Constitution said that you
should do Nancy Pelosi if you feel that
it's this dire of a situation so I'm
sorry
just like we respond to thoughts and
prayers by politicians when some some
some kid goes and shoots up another kid
at a school and they respond with
thoughts and prayers and we dismissed
that because it's useless it's there's
nothing that's there guys like you know
as much as I'm a believer like my
favorite scripture is faith without
works is dead so you're sitting there
praying and you ain't doing nothing
about it
God doesn't even recognize that right so
I mean and and then forget about divine
intervention when you have the capacity
and the tools at your disposal to
actually do something about it but
instead you're gonna pray for the
president okay or pray for that man
you're gonna pray for the United States
of America well thank you but you know
what don't pray impeach